next question today and of course you
can submit questions however you want
Twitter Instagram Facebook email I don't
know what else call in during live calls
and ask a question voicemail at two one
nine to david p next question hey David
the same people that are against
political correctness and language
policing are not now talking about in
cells as a group that has to be rescued
and babied why not forget the political
correctness and authoritarian language
policing and call them what they are
losers who can't get laid
who sit around posting memes on the
Internet okay so you've left what are in
cells that's the first question in cell
is a contraction for involuntarily
celibate involuntarily celibate the idea
basically means you're celibate despite
the fact that you don't want to be
celibate you would like to be engaging
in sexual encounters but you're unable
to because of something that's going on
that is beyond your control you ought
your or maybe not beyond control but
something you you something about you is
preventing you from being able to find
sexual partners yeah there is a
hypocrisy there because there is a
movement now that on the one hand boasts
about being against political
correctness and language policing and
for people saying whatever they want
whatever they feel all the time but at
the same time they've taken the
perspective on this insell thing but
because it's so damaging to society to
have involuntarily celibate people and
people like Jordan Peterson have made
the case that there are you know even
terrorist attacks that aren't based on
religious beliefs or mental illness or
bad family upbringing or whatever but
are because the individual who committed
the terrorist act was involuntarily
celibate there are those who say we need
to really coddle these people and sort
of create a de facto safe space for them
where they can have sex despite the fact
that the free market of dating and
finding sexual partners seems
to lead to them not being able to find
those sexual partners you've identified
a glaring double standard there's no way
that I can even mitigate it it's just it
is what it is it's a huge double
standard if you are for the free market
determining outcomes if you're against
equality of outcome if you are against
propping up those who are lacking in a
certain area despite the fact that they
may not have quote earned that support
how can you say that we need to baby in
cells and figure out way to force sexual
force them on to others as sexual
partners it makes no sense
it's absolutely ridiculous and these
people should certainly look in
themselves and figure out wait a second
if I'm subscribing to so many of these
ideologies being against equality of
outcome being against language policing
finding political correctness to be
hugely damaging why am I not simply
saying hey these are dudes who can't get
laid and that's their problem and the
free-market should should find a
solution I'm not saying that's
necessarily my view it's it's not that
far off I think providing healthcare to
everybody is more more important than
finding sexual partners for people who
are who are struggling to do that but
it's a huge double standard and they
should figure out that they're there
there are these massive inconsistencies
there